hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
ah
i'm just checking in on you just
checking in on you
seeing how your week's going how
everything's going for you how's it
going for you
in milwaukee ladies and gentlemen
they went down two games tonight
their first nba finals since 1971
backs against the wall
come back to milwaukee win game three
bam
game four the whole [ __ ] game it
looked like
it looked like the suns were gonna win
by like i don't know six to eight
then all of a sudden milwaukee comes
back i had to leave i was in a cigar bar
and i had to go to a spot over
[ __ ] uh over at lago
left with like three minutes left so i
missed the block i went home
i turned on espn i watched it
um huge block i mean it reminds me of
the one in uh lebron james you talk
about some of the big
blocks in nba finals history
um the one lebron had when he's with the
cavaliers
playing the uh warriors um
was that 2016 maybe i don't even know
um but giannis
antetokounmpo i say right um
they never say his [ __ ] last name
giannis antita campo did i say i don't
[ __ ] know
i'm not looking it up i can't spell it
but anyway it's all tied up
2-2 you know that's good for the people
in milwaukee
and anybody who wants the nba season to
extend
which i do i'm [ __ ] psyched the bucks
and the suns are in the finals how great
is that it's like the 70s
all over again um i don't know but at
the end of the game uh was it wilbon and
um
jefferson was still picking the suns it
kind of looks like the suns are more
talented
and uh if you talk to any milwaukee fan
they'll say they have a better coach but
we shall see
we shall see very excited for the bucks
milwaukee
i haven't mentioned it's one of my
favorite cities i think i have i got a
show coming up there later on in the
fall i can't wait
i can't wait i think i'm going out there
with dean delray i might bring nate
craig too
he's from [ __ ] wisconsin so he knows
where to get all the brats
and some [ __ ] uh milkshakes uh
malted milkshakes right off of a goddamn
farm
speaking of that speaking of milkshakes
oh billy fat tits oh uh billy uh plum
pecker doesn't make any sense your dick
doesn't get fat imagine you gain weight
in your dick got bigger
how many fat [ __ ] of me walking around
yeah but i could satisfy her
um weighing in after tipping the scales
that jesus is 190
maybe even 191 pounds i'm down to
183.222
just [ __ ] i'm making the gym a
priority
i'm watching what i eat yeah i'm on like
psycho regimen right now
the other night i was hungry right
before i went out i was like [ __ ]
so i had like a spoonful of peanut
butter i'll tell you it filled me up
i don't know why the [ __ ] all of these
months the past four or five months
i would stop at a food truck and get
like a [ __ ]
a torta my latino listeners told me that
ordering a burrito was the stupid white
boy one so i'm like all right well i
want to be cool
i want to order the right [ __ ] food
right so but eating those i don't know
why i did it
ice cream sandwiches why did i do it oh
that's right because it's delicious
because in the in the moment
in the moment when you're eating [ __ ]
food just the [ __ ] the rushes the
sugars the salts
the highs the lows the sobbing
afterwards
trying to find a dumpster to puke behind
is that a bad thing you know i know like
people have like eating disorders but if
you actually ate bad food is it a bad
thing to go around the corner and
[ __ ] puke it out
then it becomes a habit i'll tell you as
far as eating disorders the ones that
amazed me the most was the chewing and
spitting
like how do you get cake in your mouth
and you don't [ __ ] swallow
it's like the the [ __ ] the discipline
these chewers and spitters have
you know as much as people say what
they're doing is awful you have to you
gotta you gotta
respect their uh
you know i mean it's over that's over
for me if i even smell cake i'm eating
it
you know when a [ __ ] lion starts
eating a goddamn gazelle does he [ __ ]
uh you know
my high quarters are getting a little
big it's in his mouth it's done it's
going down the gullet bones it all
oh man i really look back man i ate like
a [ __ ]
animal i had a great time getting fat
i would go to the gr we would [ __ ]
you know what's the dane you know what's
the worst is when when both you
and the person you're with the he the
she
the they oh he's progressive
you know hey back in the day they meant
you're having a threesome
okay um whoever you're with
if they're eating bad too then you
become like sid and nancy but with like
food what do you want to do today i kind
of want something yummy what do you want
to get
you know you get all excited like
junkies you're all excited
if you're eating healthy you just like
you want to do vegan
i don't know i will if you do like
i could uh
i could cut up some broccoli and uh put
some olive oil a little bit of salt on
it and
roast it in the oven
you want me to do that
yeah i yeah i mean if we got it i mean
we should eat it
that's what healthy eating's like
all right brussels sprouts are good if
you put them on top they got vitamin
whatever in them
yeah i mean i mean we bought you know
whatever it's kind of like eating grass
but
i don't have any hope you know
but when you guys both make a [ __ ]
a decision you're going to eat bad
like when two cokeheads meet each other
right they don't know each other
one guy goes hey do you party which
you know i was talking to versi about
that that just means do you do coke
hey man do you party yeah man i party
and then the excitement they have is
they're walking down to the bathroom
not knowing if they're gonna come
walking back out that door again that's
what [ __ ] order and bad food with
with your [ __ ] with you lady is like
what do you want to get huh how about
this [ __ ] cheeseburger you want to
get [ __ ] cheeseburger
yeah yeah we get that they got that
crispy on the outside and juicy on the
inside and [ __ ] french fries
huh then have a [ __ ] shake afterwards
then you eat it you're like [ __ ]
delicious
shoving fries in just get ramping up the
salt
sending it up to the stratosphere so you
can bring it all back down with the
sugar
try to level out
i just pictured an airline pilot doing
that salt's too high i'm not gonna be
able to land this [ __ ]
[Music]
give me an italian ice yeah that's what
we were doing i would uh
i'd go out and do spots and then i would
say to her cause like you know when you
want to eat bad you want somebody else
to say they're gonna do it too
so i would just text her and be like hey
you want anything
she's like yeah i was kind of hungry and
i'd be like yes
[ __ ] psyched right so i would stop
off at our local grocery store
and i'd buy these [ __ ] ice cream
sandwiches
this is back when i was on the weed
right
so then i eat like a [ __ ] gummy then
i come home and i eat that ice cream
sandwich
and i gotta be honest with you when i
really look back on my life i don't
think i've ever been happier than
in those moments
five to ten milligrams next to my
beautiful wife watching stupid tv
eating an ice cream sandwich and that is
my question if there is a higher power
someday
you know and i meet god i
i want to be like why can't you just do
that and stay healthy
why do you gotta [ __ ] eat all of this
other [ __ ]
and he'd be like are you talking about
lettuce
what kind of celery all that green [ __ ]
i mean it's good i like to have it but
how come i can't how come i can't come
over every night have a cheeseburger and
a [ __ ] ice cream sandwich
smoke a little [ __ ] weed why can't i
[ __ ] do that and not look like it
[ __ ] such a pain in the ass like do
you realize i'm not gonna have an ice
cream sandwich until like [ __ ] if i'm
gonna get all my weight off i can't have
anything good until like [ __ ]
september
i did it to myself though i used up all
my fun days for the year i already did
it
you know what i mean like if you had a
chart how many ice cream sandwiches
could you have like i'm in the [ __ ]
red
oh billy red face old fat
freckles of [ __ ] fat tits lane
just rolling me down the hill i was on
my way to driving a minivan
and having a guess when you know you're
fat you drive a minivan and you got to
get in in that back sliding door
[Music]
[Laughter]
you take out the passenger seat
you just [ __ ] get in there you got to
take off the [ __ ] arm rest
that sound of faux leather is just
sitting down in it
that's when you've just completely lost
it you know
that's what happens if you don't go back
to salads for a while
i don't know
as you can tell i'm [ __ ] like the
high of eating well and going out and
[ __ ] working out is worn off and now
i'm just
looking at the [ __ ] fat mountain in
front of me i still gotta [ __ ] climb
here
so but good thing i didn't like you know
get into like
crazy fat or even just like 30 pounds
overweight
30 pounds overweight you're just like ah
[ __ ] there goes my summer
you know i'll be like the boy in the
bubble except i'll be on an elliptical
everybody out there playing frisbee and
trackball
and all those games from the 70s i don't
know what kids do nowadays
what do they do [ __ ] put a headset on
and do some [ __ ] talk to their friends
rather than come over
you know the good thing though about
playing video games
with your friends as a kid over the
screen and they're not there
you know they don't hear your parents
arguing you can hit mute
like dad shut up i'm playing [ __ ]
halo is that a game hulu
um so anyway
but uh last night's the first night i
went out and i did a set with jeff the
t-shirt on
still wasn't looking too good but you
know
you know when you get to that you get to
that that weight where your your belly
looks like a third pec
you know it doesn't what it does is then
it makes you your [ __ ] pecs look like
two more stomachs
you know that that [ __ ] weight
you know that that sitting on the couch
and you go to lean over and grab
something you feel the [ __ ] rolls in
the side yeah i was getting in that way
and i'm like all right i can't do this
i can't i mean i am unsightly enough i
can't i can't be doing this [ __ ] so
anyway uh i think i can get down to 182
by sunday
i'm trying to do three pounds a week
that's my goal so then next week
a week from this sunday i'd be 179 i'd
see the sevenths i go from the nines to
the eights to the sevenths
that's when it gets exciting that's when
i start field
that's when i start feeling like i'm
enough
is when i get to that weight uh and i'm
not stopping this time either
i'm going down [ __ ] marvin hagler 510
that was his weigh-in when he fought
[ __ ] tommy hearns
um but i'm eating a bunch of protein too
so i don't just i'm not gonna be like
fleshy
i'm hoping oh god is anything worse than
a [ __ ] skinny fleshy
ginger looking like a piece of tilapia i
don't want to do that
um [ __ ] hate myself right now why did
i do this to myself
jesus christ i'm going back to boston
for 10 days
and i gotta lay off all my favorite
[ __ ] spots
the amount of cardio i'm gonna have to
do you know i'm gonna this one i'm gonna
do i'm just gonna eat perfect the whole
day and then one
nah but then once a day if i eat bad
i'll be [ __ ]
yeah jesus anyway i've been listening to
uh
a lot of music you know what i love
listen to uh
little steven's uh little stevie's
garage is that what it's the show's
called it's on sirius xm
or sirius whatever i guess xm doesn't
exist anymore
and they got like the best djs on
they're all like [ __ ]
cool and funny switching some woman last
night she was cracking me up
and uh she played this song by the
ramones
which uh sad to say like i don't i only
know the ramones like radio [ __ ]
but they play like uh deep cuts on that
and i'll tell you right now it is hard
to hit spotif on spotify um
what is that app shazam it's really hard
to shazam
a [ __ ] ramone song because they're so
goddamn short by the time you [ __ ]
get it out to listen it already went by
it was a song called yeah yeah y-e-a
comma y-e-a and i was like i [ __ ]
like this song and
for some reason now i'm finally really
getting into them and realizing what an
amazing band they are
um there's a song by the blips all of
these there was something else some
chocolate wrist watch these [ __ ]
bands i'd never even heard of these guys
um which i think they were the ones that
sounded they sounded like paul mccartney
doing little richard
so i was like i kind of can i guess i'm
kind of guessing when this music came
out like post beatles
um post little richard uh that type of
uh
the last one i was talking about the
wristwatch one so anyway
sh uh i've been listening to that stuff
playing some drums having a good time
with that
but um i gotta tell you uh
you know my mother-in-law comes over to
help watch the kids and uh
she always puts on cnn and do you know
what those
[ __ ] morons are doing do you know
what those [ __ ] morons are doing
they're [ __ ] talking about trump
i swear to god i cannot believe people
watch that channel this they're so
dumb it's like do you think these people
give a [ __ ]
who's prince they want darth vader to
come back they want him to come back
because they got nothing to talk about
because it's show business and joe biden
is a [ __ ] boar
they can't [ __ ] about him because he's
wearing a blue tie
so now what do they do they're going out
there they're doing what they did the
first time
to get this guy elected by giving them
all this free coverage
while they act like they allegedly don't
like him i don't buy it
i don't buy it they're a corporate news
channel
and they just they're just they're
[ __ ] treasonous un-american pieces of
[ __ ] just like fox news msnbc just like
all of them
just like [ __ ] all of them i was at
the gym the other day right
you know oh [ __ ] billy big boobs
right
i'm on the elliptical and they had cnn
on with the sound down and i wanted to
ask him can you turn the [ __ ] channel
no they didn't have the sound down they
made it seem like all of california was
on fire which i know it is but like
there's nothing i could do about it
all right and then then they go okay and
then uh
now let's talk covet and the numbers are
up
it's just like what is their [ __ ]
deal on those on those channels
don't they have any idea what they're
doing to you cycle here i am at the
[ __ ] gym
trying to work off a bunch of goddamn
ice cream sundaes
and all i get is [ __ ] fires and
pandemic [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] you know how about a
positive story i swear to god if i ran a
24-hour news network
you know our brand would be we give you
too bad but we still
give you one good two steps back but one
step forward
give you a couple of good stories
you do a story that involves uh race
relations where
people are actually getting along
well that doesn't get ratings you have
to make them feel like [ __ ]
you have to scare the hell out of them
you got to make them feel like they got
a virus their house is going to burn
down
and uh and that the [ __ ] the nazis
are coming back
to us those are the tent poles that make
for a great
uh uh uh half hour news
if they don't have a gun in their mouth
by 18 minutes in then then we're not
doing our job
i think that that's what they say you
know
can you imagine that was your [ __ ]
job you just go on tv every day and lie
and and get people to be against each
other and
just have everybody just sort of walking
around
in a low to high level of hysteria
it's like [ __ ] like the guys in the
nhl whose job it is to go out there and
stir it up
you know slashing and [ __ ] sparing
people
and the refs not looking just pissing
people off let's get a little chippy out
there that that's how the news channels
like it they want it to be a little
chippy
you know be a great [ __ ] prank is to
somehow
like hack into them they're whatever
their news feed is and it's just nothing
but good news
and just watch to see if they could do
it
because everything they're saying
anyways is biased right so who gives a
[ __ ] if you lie about it right that's
what everybody's doing on the internet
aren't they
they're goddamn [ __ ] instagram pages
holding your phone up
so you're up your number you're a four
but you want to look like a six you
stretch your little [ __ ] t-rex arms
up over your [ __ ] slightly above
average size head
so it doesn't look as big like look at
her way down there
she's cute as a button ground's coming
up
ground's coming up [ __ ] she's a four
um four's not bad
four's not bad when you're [ __ ] uh
billy pink tits over here
oh god i [ __ ] hate myself right now
all right let's do um
let's do uh let's do some reeds here
oh all birds all the birds are brown
do you know right outside our windowsill
some bird i don't know what
its nationality is i don't know what it
identifies
um he him or she they or
[ __ ] us we um
made a nest in one of our flower pots
right outside my daughter's room and
it's sitting on the eggs
had two eggs and they hatched the other
day and there's two little
birds chirping in there and then the
dude bird
sits on like a tree close by and watches
out make sure everybody's all right
and i don't know if he brings her food
or when she goes
to go get some food he [ __ ] sits on
the eggs or what but uh
the whole thing was working and we have
this cat that kind of you know
it's a cat it doesn't give a [ __ ] right
fences it doesn't matter it doesn't
respect boundaries
you know has a very native american vibe
like hey man like
this is the land like nobody owns it man
right
so the thing's always sitting in the
driveway and i love the cat my wife
hates the cat god damn cat
you know what [ __ ] here do you know what
[ __ ] in the driveway the other day
do you realize that cat that you're not
mad at [ __ ] in the [ __ ] driveway
and i'm like oh yeah that's great that's
a good thing
she's like how is that a good thing i go
because the [ __ ] rats and the mice
smell
cat [ __ ] and they're gonna go somewhere
else it's last time you saw a mouse
around here
she's like well we had one it's like a
year ago
that [ __ ] mouse is probably dead
or it's smartened up and [ __ ] moved
on
um but anyway now i'm kind of looking at
the cat i'm like oh my god
because my daughter is just watching
this mama bird and the two little chicks
now she's like she peeks
i try not to look cause the [ __ ]
birds always looking at me is like i
don't want to freak her out
but uh she peaks and um
she thinks it's so like you know it's
like magic to her so now i'm looking at
that cat going like
okay you could hop up there and then
shimmy up on the spout
and it would go on there and just
[ __ ] kill all three of them i can't
have that if that happens like how the
[ __ ] am i going to talk to my daughter
about that
um that would be a uh
you know what do i go do i go do i go
red state on that one
you should let her watch it you should
let her learn about nature see what it's
all about you know i could go that route
right
um but uh yeah i don't want that to
happen so that now all of a sudden i'm
kind of like looking at the cat like
yeah hey why don't you uh you know kind
of [ __ ] off for a little bit
for a little bit right mice don't eat
birds
why don't you take a walk there buddy
all you got to do with a cat
right to get him to leave
you know is if you don't have a
slingshot all you got to do is just like
uh
like a water pistol but like i don't
know i always thought the slingshot made
a bigger statement that was kind of a
big thing for me when i was a kid
you know getting the biggest sharpest
rock i could find
you know just getting a [ __ ] hit him
right in the neck
watching him jump up i never did that
[ __ ] i'm kidding i just want to get all
you peter [ __ ] up in a [ __ ] uproar
um did i finish reading the whole
[ __ ] i don't know if i did did i do
did i do the advertising i don't think i
did
uh all birds everybody summer is here
it is hot and we're starting to feel
more hopeful about the rest of the year
great
i like hope i like positivity uh it's
time to get out there with all birds
lace up and feel good with all birds and
they're sustainably made tree
runner shoes oh see here's some positive
stuff these are new companies
that have been advertising who actually
build
products that are biodegradable
okay all you youngsters out there you
want to make your money and all that
stuff and uh create your your
uh companies i hope you guys do it this
way because this i really love
when you know you're advertising
something that's not gonna make the
world more polluted
anyway perfect style uh
support and made from natural materials
what's not to love
all birds are not just your average
everyday shoes but they will literally
be your favorite shoes to wear
every day once you get your hands on
these tree runners
uh these shoes are unbelievably
comfortable and light on your feet i
love that they
they're made sustainably i already said
that but they wrote it there just in
case i didn't say it
they're the most eco-friendly shoes in
the game man
made from sustainably sustainable
natural materials that feel
light on your feet and are better for
the planet the tree runners are
breathable machine washable
they'll stay new forever and made with
responsibly sourced
eucalyptus tree fiber sugar cane-based
sweet foam tm midsoles made with the
first
carbon negative eva resin
packaging made from 90 recycled
cardboard that's a shoebox
shopping bag and a mailer all in one all
birds has been dedicated to reducing
environmental impacts since day one
that's awesome from operation to
productions they treat the plant
plant it like a key stakeholder in the
company
uh certified i wish more people did that
certified as a public benefit
corporation
uh keep things light and breezy with all
birds tree runner
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com today that's all
dot-com i'm gonna get a [ __ ] pair of
these man you know
if you're gonna walk the walk you know
you gotta talk to talk right
no how does it go if you're gonna walk
to walk you gotta get this i could
[ __ ] wear those
i like the all-black ones
i like those a lot
let me see the gray you got gray and
white i like those too
navy and white jet black
all black and [ __ ] uh white one
on your fancy nights
you know what those work for me i'm
getting a [ __ ] pair
drop a little more weight no billy fat
feet over here gonna be [ __ ]
two sizes wider oh dude i had such a
good time i'm talking like ice cream and
brownies i mean i just i was just eating
like a [ __ ]
i don't know what
hey is anybody who like lives who like
listens this podcast are you bedridden
you know what i mean
you ate like that much i'm rooting for
you to lose the weight by the way but i
was wondering like what was that
what was it like the day when you
realized you couldn't get out of your
[ __ ] house man
how are you not claustrophobic it's got
to be terrifying
you know you just get that big you get
so big you can't come to work anymore
i'll tell you what's nuts he should get
that [ __ ] big and somebody's gonna
take care of you
so you kind of win you get to keep
eating like that
i've seen a couple of shows like my 600
pound life
i love when the person who's like that
big and needs to be waited on
right so he's got to come in and power
wash him everything
[Music]
like the side of like an aluminum house
right
i always just [ __ ] just sit there and
thinking like when you just be like
ridiculously nice
i would just be sitting there as he'll
[ __ ] hit me with that fire hose
just be like i'm sorry like yelling over
the water as i was eating another
[ __ ] english muffin oh god i'd love
an english muffin right now
oh the [ __ ] butter and the nooks and
crannies
i really am a closeted fat person i just
have too much of a need to be
liked to become just like you know
just some big fat titted [ __ ]
something or other
you know which it's actually a good
thing i don't think people should be
shamed anymore for being fat
because they're they're hastening the
the their their life expectancy
which at this point consider we've had a
lot of 130 degree days
in places which is literally i guess
it's not even you can't even
survive if you're outside um
it's kind of a good thing because there
needs to be less people
so you know if you're trying to lose
weight
i'm rooting for you but if you're not
trying to lose weight i say keep going
keep going i passed the torch to you
everything i was doing in the last six
months
all right you [ __ ] do it
you eat that that [ __ ] fudge cake
brownie whatever the [ __ ] i was eating
you do that [ __ ]
and you enjoy it
this has nothing to do with you guys
this has to do with me because i think
about that sometimes
there's there's always that or i could
eat myself to death that would be
[ __ ] great
it's got to be you know
no i know you feel like [ __ ] but it's
just got to be great when you want a
pizza you just get one
and you just keep eating them until
you're full instead of being like okay
i'm just gonna have one
i just don't understand why the world
has to be like that
like whoever created this [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] did you make heroin you douche
why did you do that if
you're gonna get like addicted to it and
all that i just don't understand i
really
feel like
like whoever have the higher power is
doesn't give a [ __ ] about us
and is more just wanting to be
entertained
you know it's like you know like the
whole world the whole universe is like a
[ __ ] giant reality
show you know like like survivor
there's all these little pitfalls and
all the blue teams doing this the red
team better catch up
oh you know that's not how you put that
puzzle together
oh and there's poppy seeds don't you put
one of those in the mouth see what [ __ ]
happened
can you just walk up to a poppy seed and
just eat it and be higher on heroin or
do they have to like add a bunch of [ __ ]
to it
i gotta figure this out this is great
for my search engine
this would be a great search here how to
make
your own heroin
massive poppy bust home brew heroin
soon anyone be able to what oh my god
soon anyone will be able to make illegal
drugs
what
i i don't feel like it's responsible to
even read this but i just said it
humble fungi and a home brewing kit
could soon
do what the combined
might of the west failed to do halt the
thriving
poppy industry in afghanistan the source
of 80 percent of the world's opium
genetically that's like the cute like
cuban cigars like all the [ __ ] heroin
comes from afghanistan genetically
engineered yeast could make it easy to
produce opiates such as morphine
anywhere
cutting out the international drug
smugglers holy [ __ ]
and making such drugs cheap and more
readily available
if home brew drugs become widespread
it would make the
system nature of stopping the
supply of illegal narcotics even more
obvious than it than it is now
well i i am of the belief though that
you should really treat
you know addicts like they they have a
disease and you should help them out
rather than put them in jail i've seen a
bunch of studies where they try to help
them out and get them please
works way better than just sticking them
in jail
um this this sick you know look at me
i'm a [ __ ] sick man
um it would be as disrupted to the drug
enforcement
policy as it would be to crime
syndicates
oh and then this is why they'll never
have this [ __ ] i don't think they'll
have this [ __ ] because all the money
they make
fighting drugs uh a bunch of people be
out of work a growing number of drugs
scents and flavors once obtainable only
from plants can now be used
can made using genetically modified
organisms
researchers want to add opiates to that
list because they are part of a family
of molecules that they have useful
medical properties
plant get the [ __ ] out of here what are
the use
criminal disruption all right this is on
new new scientist.com
it's an article called homebrew heroin
soon anyone will be able to
make legal drugs hey honey you want to
make some heroin tonight
uh we got the kids this weekend can we
do it next weekend okay
you'll be great if they could make like
[ __ ] heroin that you're not like
addicted to
or if the government had all the heroin
and just like once a year you came in
and you just it's not off day
and everybody gets to try it and [ __ ]
nod off and then you're fine
you know like the super bowl once a year
um well this is one of the weirder
podcasts i had
uh but i'm in a weird mood all right
that's it everybody that's the podcast
enjoy your weekend congratulations to
the milwaukee bucks tying it up
and uh for making it an exciting series
because obviously
phoenix went up three games to one that
was pretty much all she wrote
unless somebody got hurt on their team
um
please enjoy the music picked out by uh
andrew thumless and then we'll have a
bonus episode
of the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast from a
year ago
or however he does it a couple of years
ago okay that's it have a great weekend
you [ __ ]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
uh july 15th 2013
barry sanders dan marino
um how are you how's it going i know the
podcast's late
i don't understand why you guys feel
like you actually have
not all you guys just to feel you
actually feel that you know when this
podcast is supposed to come about
you know it's called the monday morning
podcast why isn't it around
on monday morning well let me ask you
this
remember that [ __ ] song led zeppelin
did that hey mama said the way you
move gonna make you sweat gonna make you
groove
remember that [ __ ] the name of that song
is called black dog
it's not about a black dog he never says
black dog
i don't like a black dog walked in the
[ __ ] studio
right wasn't wearing a hoodie
so nobody shot it john bonham didn't
have to stand his ground
all right the [ __ ] dog came walking
in
and uh then they just called the song
black dog
so there you go the monday morning
podcast
i do it monday mornings when i wake up
when i'm in town i was on a [ __ ]
plane this monday morning
flying from [ __ ] from
boston baw people not bah
you midwestern [ __ ] thinking you could
do a boston accent it's bar
b-a-w boston the red sox
s-a-w-x like saw like you're gonna saw
down the tree
can you figure that out there mr green
jeans when you're not out there planting
food for the [ __ ] country
well can you all right then i was just
asking
you don't have to grab your little
shoulder straps on your overalls
by the way what is that pocket for
between your man tits what do you stick
in there huh your remote control
huh you stick something in there for
whittling
did you go scrub your nails um
[ __ ] was i talking about oh yeah i was
flying back from boston
and uh i got upgraded this is a classic
example
of cold lotion everybody all right i'm
in the back of the plane with the
[ __ ] animals
right all of us back there clamoring
around
you know we all sucked at math or maybe
we were good at math we just weren't
good at [ __ ]
you know getting along with people which
one is one of the keys
main keys to success people
you got to be a good [ __ ] i don't care
how smart
you are you got to be somebody that
people want to be around
all right if albert einstein was a [ __ ]
you know just think of how many more
japanese people would be around today
that's so bad i'm sorry i can never get
past
that he made the bomb he didn't have to
do it
you know [ __ ] people asking him to
make the goddamn thing they didn't know
how to do it
he could have just been like yeah i
don't know how to make something like
that
you know you're gonna have to earn this
one there sergeant riker um
all right i probably offended at least
nine different races at this point let's
uh let's keep going here
i know there's a point here somewhere so
i'm flying back so i i'm in the back of
the plane right
with the people who say what they feel
to their boss
the people who sucked at math the people
who [ __ ] knocked up somebody that
they're not in love with
you know i don't know what i don't know
what we did
to deserve to be in the back of that
[ __ ] plane
all right but we're back there and all
of a sudden
i get a little [ __ ] tap on the
shoulder and says mr burr
um this is there's a spot up in our
first class cabin
there's a space available you've been
upgraded
you know and what do i say
do i say no i'm not going i'm staying
with my people
you know the downtrodden the mentally
challenged
not in a uh mentally challenged kind of
way just like
and uh that guy's not all there kind of
way you know
[Laughter]
huh do i [ __ ] hang in there like
william wallace as they pull out my
entrails trying to drag me in the first
class and say no
i'm not going i'm going to stand my
ground
i'm going to stay here in the [ __ ]
the
the the the main cabin i look out the
main [ __ ] cabin
right like you're feeling like oh this
is the main this is the [ __ ] i'm in the
main
i'm vip no you're not
you should call it the [ __ ] corral or
something like the stockade
anyways did i stay with my people no i
didn't i sold them out
i said [ __ ] this i'm out like the leader
of a union
spooning with some guy that smells like
clam sauce
there's another group um
and i go up to the front so i went from
my [ __ ] knees and my chest
highlights magazine right right my face
you know whatever they have there
the sky mall you know
case you want to buy a [ __ ] mickey
mouse uh ashtray whatever the hell they
have
slash ipod charger that's my joke that
me and joe always do our joke i should
say about bobby kelly
whatever gadget he has it always ends
with and it
charges my ipod yet
dude i just bought a [ __ ] dildo dude
it goes clockwise counterclockwise and
it charges my iphone dude
um
i'm sorry so anyway so i go up there i'm
[ __ ] excited as hell
gonna sit in first class with all the
big boys all the blood money
right everybody up there you know some
bearded fellow with curly cues and
diamonds under his hat i'm up front
i'm up front with the blue bloods people
who own horses
just to own them because they think
they're cute not because they got to go
[ __ ] till the land
that's how you say it so i get up my
seat
the only thing suck was i was a very
front row so you can't you can't put
your [ __ ]
under the person in front of you so i
had to look for an overhead compartment
space people if you could just put your
bags in the overhead compartment so we
could
expedite the boarding process we're
trying to have an
on-time departure um
ugh they all say the same thing and i
fly all the airlines
i [ __ ] around um
anyways so i [ __ ] get up there and i
sit down on my first class [ __ ] cabin
seat
it's 6 50 in the morning flight all
right
i have a nice giant pillow i have a nice
blanket
first class everything's nice you know
pay for it all those poor saps back in
the main cabin
you know some lady going into labor
three months in because her knees are so
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] up to her chin they don't care
i don't care when she has a little
three-pound baby as we fly over the
rockies they don't care
they don't give a [ __ ] to them that's
just another three pound animal
to stuff in the back of the [ __ ]
plane and at this point i don't care
because i'm selfish i'm about me i'm up
front
i'm rubbing elbows with bankers you know
i'm the only person up there without
cufflinks you know
standing out like i shouldn't be at the
party but there's nothing they can say
about
so anyways i probably got two hours
sleep
which is the best way to get on a plane
when you have a long flight
okay that is the all-natural way of
knocking yourself out
rather than taking some designer drug
that's going to put your liver in a full
nelson you know
maybe choke it out and give hammer
another seven hammer fists before that
ufc ref can slide over
you know my only complaint about the ufc
you know when was the last time somebody
got knocked out and then didn't get an
additional four what was the [ __ ]
guys going i've never understood that
aspect of ultimate fighting
the [ __ ] guy is out you could see
he's out
and if you don't know he's out the
entire crowd going
oh doesn't let you know
he's out laying on the ground you know
you fall down whenever you get knocked
out
it's funny because like your legs cross
like you're watching television
like enjoying your day off and then your
arms
they always like they're kind of moving
like rocking back like
have you noticed that they always like
go up like you're still in fighting mode
and but they're sort of like shaking
like uh
i don't know like your legs are like
drilled into the ground
and you're up you'll get a toy and
somebody just flicked your head
[ __ ] yeah whatever you've seen this
[ __ ] so anyway
i've got on to that so anyway so i sit
down there and i'm just like all right
all right that's your liver [ __ ] you
don't want to do that
all right if you want to sleep on a
flight just don't go to sleep if don't
sleep the night before your flight i
mean how [ __ ] easy is that
how lazy are you do you get that from
your parents i mean what's wrong with
you
i don't think you should be listening to
this podcast right now i think you
should sit down
have a little quiet time and figure out
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
i'm seriously repulsed by you right now
if you if you fit into the definition of
this all right
so just don't go to sleep that's what i
did
i stayed up with [ __ ] new the pride
in newark's paul verzi
and uh i got two hours of sleep
i drove my rented kia um
back to budget
and uh yeah whatever i get on the
[ __ ] plane so i'm just gonna go to
sleep and i go to press the button
to recline my seat and my seat is broken
it won't recline all right i got
upgraded to first class and my
but my seat wouldn't recline and right
there people
because there's a lot of confusion out
there right there that is a classic
example of some cold lotion
okay they're doing something nice for
you
but then there's an awful experience
involved
right look up the definition
because i'm sick of people sending me
[ __ ] on twitter going oh you know
this guy sent me one i went to the
summer league and i watched my you know
portland trailblazers but they lost to
the lakers that's some cold lotion
no it isn't the lakers didn't say hey
we're gonna [ __ ] uh
we're gonna lose on purpose tonight
you know don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about sir
so anyways now i'm [ __ ] sleeping
upright
you know though i swear to god those
goddamn
chairs on airplanes are just unforgiving
first of all the fuselage is just far
enough away from your head
that it's going to kill your neck if you
try and lean your head on it so then you
get the pillow and the pillow's a piece
of [ __ ]
front or back of the plane the feathers
just scatter especially when you got a
big
head like mine so you can't get that
then you try to turn to the side
right you try to turn and lay at an
angle then you got the uh the arm rest
which it feels like a [ __ ] pistol
stuck in your side
that's the worst you know i just threw
the blanket over my head
because i forgot my eye mask and uh
did you see superman and eye mask
um sorry um whatever i just want to give
you an example of what [ __ ] cold
lotion is or look it up on the urban
dictionary they have a great explanation
of what it is
i'm tired of [ __ ] correcting people
on twitter
tired of that that you can tell i've
done three shows this weekend screaming
my brains out because i don't know how
to write a joke
i sound like peter brady right now um
i'm sick of that on twitter and then i'm
also sick of the [ __ ] uh
people who go first world problems
all right that's that's the latest in
the
the the list that i'm beginning for
twitter hack
all right what do we have so far we have
anything that begins
with that feeling when that moment
when or if you go wait what
right i want the last such and such
time of my life back i just threw up a
little bit in my mouth
all of these you've heard thousands of
[ __ ] times
yet for some reason a select
90 percent of people on twitter continue
to use them as if they're still funny
the same [ __ ] people would go out to
go see a comedian
and if they did the same [ __ ] that they
already saw him do on tv they'd be like
the show
sucked you know
then they go on twitter and they [ __ ]
hack it up
now i know i'm being harsh on you guys
because you're just civilians but if you
want to enter
the wonderful world of joke writing you
need to step
up your [ __ ] game why don't you try
to find your own voice on twitter
and 180 word [ __ ] letters or less
whatever it is
all right i'll tell you right now
i'm a little disappointed in a lot of
you you're better than that
okay first of all if you live in a first
world
you should never tell somebody that's a
first world [ __ ] problem as if to
remove yourself
from your spoiled existence you know
like you don't have some roast beef in
the fridge that you didn't have to go
out and kill
and maybe lose your oldest son trying to
bring that [ __ ] yak down
right is that where roast bees come from
where does roast beef come from that's
some sort of steer i guess that's a
steer cow you get the milk
right unless it [ __ ] beats up other
cows and then they [ __ ] kill it and
they make steaks
stairs you get the steaks rub roasts and
all that [ __ ] and then
bulls bulls go around they [ __ ] the cows
to make more stairs and more cows am i
right
anybody anybody out there or farmer
anybody out there in the [ __ ] cattle
game
the cattle game that's that's a new
movie i'm working on the cattle game
it's about a cow that has a dick and a
[Music]
[Laughter]
and it surprises an unsuspecting bull
because it's already fell in love with
them
i just spoiled the secret of the cattle
game everybody
um this is the weirdest [ __ ] podcast
ever all right let's do a little bit of
advertising here everybody all right so
i can keep the podcast free
for all you [ __ ] whining [ __ ] out
there
um i don't want to pay for the podcast
there's too much advertising pick a
[ __ ] side mary
uh legal zoom everybody uh i
whoops that's not it
that was like a commentary on the
[ __ ] thing what the hell is it
all right [ __ ] it let's call it audible
like i just came up to the line
you know after calling a play and i see
a defense and i'm giving a look to my
[ __ ] receiver right all i gotta do is
give him a look
marvin harrison out there did you kill
anybody last night
who did you kill last night wide
receiver
uh tivo everybody uh before tevo
watching tv was weirdly hard
weirdly hard i don't think it was i
think it was pretty basic
you know you turned it on you sat down
you looked at it
i got issues with that but you know what
i'm going to be a company man and i'm
going to play ball here
bill burr reads the tivo ad take two
me me me me me me me me me me tivo
um before tevo watching tv was weirdly
hard
you could only watch a show at a certain
time and if you missed it
or even a part of it you literally had
to wait for it to go into reruns before
you could see it again
now i'm old enough to tell you that
that's a hundred percent true
you missed one episode of happy days you
didn't know what was going on
how did chachi knock up joni
when did they have a kid well you missed
last week's episode
have fun wait until july thank god
that's all over
because tivo totally changed all of that
and while our other dvrs exist they're
not as
sickalicious as tivo oh they're trying
to get the young market here
because if you have cable tivo lets you
watch your shows wherever you want
with tivo stream you can watch on your
ipad all over your house
that's awesome man i actually have a
little mini ipad no
i gotta get this instead of just talking
about it i should take
action and even transfer your favorite
recordings and take them with you
on an airplane waiting in line at the
dmv
dentist's office tivo makes other dvrs
look like they were designed by some
soviet committee
huh take that one people over there in
partial europe and asia
only tivo searches for both cable and
web to find any movie
any show any video at the press of a
button netflix
amazon youtube now those are just
i was doing so well wasn't i now those
are just like more channels on your tv
and with the tivo mini one tivo box
works on a second tv
from the couch to the kitchen from the
minivan to 35 000 feet
tivol tivo makes tv about a thousand
times better
i don't know about you guys but i'm sold
that's another great way to make a
flight go by i'll watch
every episode of welcome back carter one
after another boop baptist
welcome back e-voice everybody
you're screening calls closing deals and
making money
all while lounging poolside in the
summer sun
thanks to who hope e-voice everybody
e-voice is a better way to connect with
the people that drive your business
e-voice will forward your business calls
to your home mobile or any number you
choose wherever
you are e-voice will find you don't have
time to take a call
no problem it's routed to your voicemail
and you can read it
at your convenience as a text message
e-voice not only gives you an edge over
your competitors it takes away
the edge the big companies have over you
right now with e-voice you can create
the appearance of a whole office
building of departments when customers
call you
a sales department customer support tech
support you name it
and it works with any phone even
yourself hey it's summer
don't be stuck in your office all day
what's wrong with you go out there and
get in the sun
look at the ladies right
or if you're a woman go look at the
fellas in their hairy pecs
you know free yourself with a free
30-day trial of e-voice you can see what
i'm talking about
or at least what i'm reading about go to
evoice.com and enter a promo code
bill for 30 days for for up sorry for a
30-day free tar
trial jesus you know i always like run
down
great i get to the horse i do my little
flips and i never stick the landing
uh that's evoice dot com promo code bill
or go to the podcast page on
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner
and lastly dollar shave club everybody
how long
have you been getting f'd in the a when
it comes to buying blades for your razor
right why are they acting like they're
little gold bullions
they're not they're little poor excuses
for metal
plastic hunks of crap and they lock them
behind the register
as if you're buying some i don't know
top shelf booze
dollar shave club everybody has made me
so much happier about shaving you know
why
i don't have to deal with it anymore
it's a great brand they send you these
quality razors right to your door every
month
okay so not only do i get them cheaper i
don't have to stand behind some blue
hair who's trying to figure out how to
use her douche bag
that she bought in the 1930s okay
you don't have to think about it you
don't have to wait in line get someone
to unlock them from a cage and pay way
too much money for a bunch of features
that don't even fit on your old handle
shaving has become a mess
all right eliminate all of that from
your life all right
the dollar shave club you know what it
does it saves me time it saves me money
and the razors are great i've used them
i dragged them right across my red face
and i was smooth as a baby's bottom but
not in a perverted way
i want you to try it do me a favor go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
support this show go to
dollarshaveclub.com or click on the
dollar shave club banner
at the podcast page billboard.com one
more time
in case you're you're on drugs that's
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
jesus christ how many times i got to
tell you jesus christ
all right back to the podcast here's
something you don't get a lot on the
podcast everybody an apology
i owe two major apologies
three jesus christ
where do i start number one i trashed
world war z
before it came out the second i saw the
rating was pg-13 if you remember from a
couple of weeks back
i said basically that the end of the
world is not pg-13
it's like nc 17 if not 18
if that's if that's actually a rating
okay
but i actually went out and i saw world
war z and i got to tell you something
i absolutely loved it not only did i
love it i feel the pg-13 rating
helped it you know because if you go out
and see my act
my act is probably nc 17 or at least
rated r
and if you really watch me i don't know
how to write a joke that's why i have to
scream and jump around and say the f
word every other word
and people still laugh because they
don't realize i'm just doing a big
parlor trick
that's all it is but the great thing is
is when you go down to pg 13 they
actually have to make a movie
i'm bs right now i'm bullshitting
everybody i kept a pg-13 there
you know i like they actually they built
suspense and actually back in the day
even in rated r movies they started
building since they used to build
suspend
suspense and one of my things that i
always hated about uh
horror movies and big time blockbusters
is once all they had all that cgi
equipment you know they could have the
perfect storm wave and all that crap
they there was no story it's just a
bunch of people and you're just sitting
there waiting for the big wave to knock
over the boat
and uh one night i watched this movie
dark night of the scarecrow
and the movie i don't know there was
really scared the [ __ ] out of me late at
night
and um i was trying to figure out why
there was really nothing i i don't i
couldn't figure out when it was they
were building suspense
they were scaring the [ __ ] out of me and
world war z did it brad pitt was awesome
so my apologies
to bradley pitt pride of missouri and
anybody else connected with uh
world war z was a [ __ ] great movie i
uh highly recommend it that's apology
number one
apology number two speaking of movies
for the last two months
i've been hyping the billy red state
tour talking about how all you guys
drive you know a lot of people drive
long distances to come and see me and i
said you know what i'm gonna come and
see you
but unfortunately actually fortunately i
i ended up getting some acting work
and uh i can't control when they shoot
stuff and it's
really a big thing for me and i couldn't
say no to it so
unfortunately the billy red state tour
oh kind of got split up um i've
rescheduled all of them
all right i'm not going to totally sell
out and just say well i got acting work
i'm not doing these i just rescheduled
them so this is the deal
um the first two dates boise idaho
in bozeman montana those ones are still
the same dates
everything else got moved um
as of right now the only rescheduled
dates i can give you is boulder colorado
is september 4th and pikes peak colorado
is september 6th and i believe we're
looking at oklahoma
and uh kansas that got moved to like
november
this is the deal i'm still coming to all
of those places just not
in the next two weeks i apologize i know
it's the summer
you probably said hey i can't go water
skiing and bang that chick i always
wanted to bang back in high school but
didn't have the balls and now i said the
right [ __ ]
you know i hope i didn't [ __ ] up
something like that for you all right
but if you're just gonna play frisbee
with some cow chips then i think you can
wait a couple of months
is that really an apology started off as
one
um and then lastly the last apology that
i have
is uh i have to apologize to jolly
jolly old england i usually watch
wimbledon every year but i've been so
busy i missed out and i ended up the one
[ __ ] year i don't watch it um the
first english champion since i don't
know when
i'm gonna guess the 1930s again andy
murray congratulations
for being the first uh human being with
dick and balls
from uh great britain
or should i say england what does great
britain
let's see the united kingdom uh who
gives a [ __ ] about geography whatever
he's from england
i wish i could have seen i mean i even
watched a clip of it to see how [ __ ]
crazy everybody went so my apologies
i should have given you guys your props
um that's awesome i'm sure you guys are
still [ __ ] celebrating i think that's
a great thing
great for the sport and uh
and speaking of sports yet another
person from overseas
sent me another video about rugby you
know one of those clips where they show
all these unbelievably hard hits
and they are hard hits you know but they
always
kind of have to come at me like saying
american football
is for [ __ ] because they wear all
this equipment so here's what i have to
say to rugby people
fans of rugby who think that american
football players
are somehow [ __ ] slash not as tough
as rugby
uh rugby players
put it this way when rugby players
like two three years after they retire
start committing suicide by shooting
themselves in the chest
because they don't want to damage their
brain so scientists can look at it
after they're dead to figure out why
they're so [ __ ] up
you know when rugby players start doing
that
okay then um
then maybe you haven't even then you
wouldn't have an argument then your
sport
would be as [ __ ] up as ours you know
and if you want to win that contest
you know our sport does more damage to
our citizens than yours does then you
know
more power to you but i'm just saying
i don't think rugby guys uh they don't
kill themselves do they
i have no [ __ ] idea i didn't i didn't
really research it one way or the other
um all right so i know a lot of people
you know i uh were asking me questions
here wanted
me to comment on that uh that case down
there in florida i gotta be honest with
you
once it went it was so racial from the
beginning
that [ __ ] just uh depresses the hell out
of me
it makes me feel like there's never
going to be any sort of progress
i think that there's progress in uh
you know maybe stuff in movies and stuff
that people
say on tv but i still think people have
a lot of the same thoughts
unfortunately they do and uh so i don't
know anything about it
all i can say is that i feel a lot of
the people some of the [ __ ] i had
actually stopped like
following like three people on twitter
because the [ __ ] they were writing was
so [ __ ] ignorant about it
um basically by ignoring me not talking
about the case making it this whole
[ __ ] race thing
and uh and people like that on both
sides i would
say that if it was flipped and the exact
opposite thing happened
you know played out the same way except
it was a 17 year old white kid that
killed
got killed by an african-american adult
those same people
would completely flip on whether they
thought it was guilt or innocence and
that's what [ __ ] drives me nuts about
the [ __ ]
and depresses me um but i mean
race was a big thing about it i could
tell you this right now if an
african-american
male adult shot a 17 year old white kid
um with who had skittles and iced tea
uh i don't know
i would not want to be the defendant in
that [ __ ] case
put it that way i wouldn't
so ah another [ __ ] unfortunate
it just gets so f you know do you really
think actually let me ask you this do
you think people are that ignorant or
that they just show the ignorant people
you know i don't [ __ ] know but i get
overwhelmingly depressed when i watch
[ __ ] like that so i kind of stayed away
from it
um so anyways
i don't know why i brought that up it's
just a it's a [ __ ] awful topic
i do have to say though for the little i
know about the stand your ground law
i don't understand why that exists
um most other states you have to
have exhausted any option of
of retreat you know
like every martial arts class you ever
take like they always say the first
[ __ ]
defense is to avoid it if you can avoid
it in any way
regardless of what hey you [ __ ] [ __ ]
your mother's a [ __ ] or whatever
that's just words you're supposed to
just walk away from something like that
you know and it's just when you get to
the point where your back's against the
wall
you know you got to defend yourself
which i 100 believe but that stand your
ground
where your wife's going like honey
they're kind of angry let's
they're drunk i think we should just i
ain't moving staying in my [ __ ]
ground
that just that just sounds that sounds
aggressive
like i don't know the stand your ground
law and i'm just
asking here before you start sending me
emails written all in capital letters
all right to me that just sounds like
you're escalating that's that's a way to
escalate a situation
you know do you know how many people
[ __ ] stood their ground and just wish
that they didn't
or in wheelchairs now or missing eyes or
[ __ ]
drool all day long and standing your
ground is one of the dumbest [ __ ]
things you can do
with a complete stranger who gives a
[ __ ] they're not in your life
you know oh is that what you think about
me person who doesn't know me and i'll
never see again
that's good okay you're right i'm
walking away
i don't know i don't know much about the
law but that reminds me a long time ago
when i watched this bouncer
he walked up there was two people
arguing
and he comes walking up and his job is
to [ __ ]
you know end the situation defuse it
right hopefully by just talking
you know see he comes walking up
and he says hey what's the problem here
and the guy talking to him goes with
this guy here blah blah blah
and he he put his hand on the bouncer
shoulder like more like hey i want to
talk to you to tell you what happened
and the bouncer immediately goes first
of all don't touch me
and i i can't do it the way he delivered
the line but i immediately started
[ __ ] die and laughing
because what he then did he just
escalated the situation and then that
guy who was mad at the other guy
took the anger he already had and then
focused it on the bouncer and then
immediately
they're both on the ground rolling
around on the floor
and it was just like what struck me is
so funny was that that bouncer came over
there and it was just like did you want
to fight the guy
why would you say that you should just
said sir
i just need you to keep your hands down
there thank you no no what what what are
you saying blah blah blah
go that way but to be like first of all
don't touch me
[ __ ] like slap his hand away or
whatever
i don't know i don't know about that
stand your ground think so i'm also very
ignorant of it you can tell so uh
let me know i'm gonna wait till
everything dies down then i'm gonna try
to read up on the [ __ ] case but i i
can't watch it
when it's like rolling stone is so
friggin to the left
and then you watch like fox news and
yeah you know you know how they are over
there like it's it's so hard to try and
get
some sort of like sanity and all of that
and uh
you combine that with every [ __ ] jerk
off who has an opinion you can write
something on the internet i just kind of
avoided the whole [ __ ] thing
um who knows all right there you go
so you asked i said it i hope i didn't
[ __ ] piss anybody off and make it any
more painful
um all right and with that hey you know
something somebody wrote something some
[ __ ] up dream to me
that they had that i was in and uh
actually wrote something funny about i
like to think funny back to
uh analyzing his dream just to give you
something else to talk and keep the
podcast fresh
if you guys want me if you had a [ __ ]
up dream over the next like six days or
maybe one you had a few weeks ago and
it's bugging you
and you want me to interpret your dreams
all right bill burr interpret your
dreams dreams dreams dreams dreams will
be a new segment hopefully
next week on the podcast and they don't
obviously not to be about me i hope i
didn't confuse anybody there all right
this is gonna be some [ __ ]
you know narcissistic thing even though
i am sitting here by myself
i'm too [ __ ] arrogant to have a guest
or lazy or whatever you want to call if
you want to [ __ ] frame it that's up
to you
i don't tell you how to think so yeah if
you have a weird [ __ ] dream
uh send it in and i'll i'll interpret
your drape
um oh by the way i want to thank
everybody who came out this week i was
in my old stomping grounds uh
went to the cape cod melody tent which
was a uh just an absolute
that was a dream come true to be able to
perform in that place it's the one and
only place i ever saw
george carlin and uh
it was amazing i couldn't believe how
small it was anytime you're in the round
like that many seats look small because
you're like cutting the ring off
it's kind of like how dan cook did it
when he would would do like those giant
arenas
it's [ __ ] brilliant because if you're
doing like a giant place like that and
you put the stage on one side
it's like that person in the last row up
top
is a zillion miles away but if you put
it in the middle
it's like you've i know you guys you can
do the [ __ ] math
you have to be in construction you know
what i mean i'm 50 closer to you
that last row is 50 closer second to
last row everything is 50
closer isn't except for like the front
row but isn't it isn't there more front
row with the circle
ah jesus i'm all confused i'm starting
to sweat here
um so anyways i went down there i just
had a
[ __ ] great time and um
i was having such a good time i forgot
to promote that i was selling my dvds
afterwards so
i apologize to anybody who wanted a
picture or something like that i did
come out afterwards
uh there was like 30 35 people there
[Laughter]
needless to say i left a lot of [ __ ]
dvds in a box
back in massachusetts um and then the
next night
i did the hampton beach ballroom casino
uh which is one of my favorite [ __ ]
gigs
um i was up there i was working with
paul version then a buddy of mine wayne
previtty
uh who i started out doing stand up with
a long time ago
back in boston we all hung out had a
great time and then the final night was
the newport yachting festival
yachting center sorry which was uh you
know an
an unair-conditioned tent in a parking
lot and it was
i don't know if it was global warming or
what but it was the hottest
it's ever been i don't know if anybody
took any pictures of me when i was on
stage
but i was wearing this button-down shirt
that was really thin and i thought was
going to be cool but all it did
it was like you ever work out wearing a
great t-shirt how [ __ ] disgusting you
look afterwards that's what i look like
um it was gross
but i hung in there and actually i got
like 50 minutes in
and then i just felt like i got like
almost like runners high
i was so [ __ ] hot and i ended i think
i did like an hour and a half was one of
the longest i've ever done on stage
standing up there and uh i just had a
great time
and consumed nine zillion calories
as i always do i i took verzi on a
[ __ ]
uh we should have filmed it on this
foodie tour
of all this [ __ ] that i used to be able
to eat in my early 20s and wake up the
next day and still have a flat stomach
dare i say abs i took it like what's
great about massachusetts if you ever go
out there
is like every two to three towns
has just some unbelievable [ __ ] place
to get pizza and there
it's i think they call it bar bar pizza
where it's basically the size of a small
pizza
and uh i'm telling you the place i have
which i'm not even going to tell you
what it is because i don't want to blow
it up
because i want to [ __ ] be able to
come back there and get a seat
um when i did the movie the heat um
nate cordrey told me about a place he
knew down off of route 3.
that was [ __ ] unbelievable and um
i don't know maybe if you guys want to
if you guys want to out some of your
spots
it's a great thing to do and then i took
him to this [ __ ] ice cream place
afterwards it's like we were on a date
took him to this ice cream place
that's right on a farm all right and you
get a small
you get a small [ __ ] dish of ice
cream right
and they put the sprinkles on the bottom
by the way in massachusetts they're
called jimmies and i just found out that
that's
what i heard that's actually racist
because i guess that was another term
for african americans back in the day
like jim crow laws
so hey there's a couple of jimmy's over
there kid or whatever so they called
because
the sprinkles a lot of times with
chocolate they called them jimmy's
all right so i probably shouldn't even
[ __ ] said that because now
racists will be like oh good a new way
to be a [ __ ]
but anyway so i always say sprinkles
when i'm up there even though that
that always makes me feel like silly
saying that like could i get some
sprinkles
i'm just a little flustered um now
is that homophobic i mean jesus it's
just a bear trap wherever you step
so whatever they put the [ __ ]
sprinkles on the bottom and the small is
basically like eating a pint of [ __ ]
ice cream so then we walk over we sit on
a bench
me and paul versi sitting on a bench in
defense of us it was made for
three all right and we're sitting there
eating ice cream looking at the cows
from the farm where i get they get the
[ __ ] cream and the milk or whatever
[ __ ] they get
uh where does the cream come out of the
cow huh is that somewhere around between
the tank
and the uh the utter there is that what
it is does it got an extra valve
you know what i mean like that one
that's just for hot water
i don't [ __ ] know so we're sitting
there and i said
i shouldn't even tell you this i'm i
can't tell you this i said i'm gonna
take a picture of us and i'm gonna send
this to nia and she's gonna [ __ ]
trash us
and that's exactly and i bet him a
dollar and of course she did
um and then so whatever we went up to
hampton beach that night
and we we do the gig um
this is a place like aerosmith when they
first started out rumors has it that led
zeppelin actually played there if they
did is probably one of
maybe uh i know they played the uh the
boston tea party
i know they played the whiskey out here
in la they played
they literally played like i think a
dozen small venues before they
absolutely blew up and just went to i
imagine large theaters and obviously
arenas
but uh last time i was there they were
claiming that that that might have been
one of the places that they played
um and also a long time ago i remember i
was in a bad relationship and i walked
up the boardwalk and i was like i want
to get out of this relationship
i want to turn my life around and i saw
george carlin's name outside of there
and i remember thinking that's what i
want to be doing i want to be doing
stand up not being in this [ __ ] up
relationship right
so we had a great time and then
i'm racing back to get some chinese food
at this place that
that i will out this place the the uh
the tahiti
and uh dead of mass and i'm telling you
right now
you can't [ __ ] with
the chinese food in massachusetts
however far it goes where they have a
poo-poo platter
they have chicken fingers they're pork
spare ribs they're crab rangoon
i'm telling you new york you don't even
know what the
[ __ ] good chinese food is
new york had the worst chinese food the
dirtiest goddamn
[ __ ] restaurants i've ever been to
the chinese food
every [ __ ] you walk in first of all
they'd be like bulletproof glass that
was all scraped
up and dirty and smudged and then there
was this filthy
[ __ ] bicycle they never mopped the
floor they were the dirtiest [ __ ]
places i've ever been to in my life
you go to [ __ ] the ones up here in
massachusetts or when i was out there
massachusetts
dude it was like a [ __ ] lounge get a
scorpio
right [ __ ] 12 drunks with 12 straws
sucking down like five different
alcohols with hawaiian punch in there
these big lounges these [ __ ] looking
like uh look at that
that [ __ ] on the brady bunch where they
lost the tiki everything but everybody
[ __ ] don ho walking by with a ukulele
which i know is hawaiian
i don't give a [ __ ] was great
insane food so i did this thing with the
uh
i hate when i have an early flight and i
have to get i have to fill up the tank
with gas because i always end up almost
missing my flight
um so finally i chose the full tank of
gas
option which sucks because then you got
to drive around on e because you don't
want to get [ __ ] because if you come
back with a half a tank they're still
charging you for a full tank
and the [ __ ] over extra price you know
for a gallon of gas
so i'm driving back from uh new
hampshire and uh
the [ __ ] light is blinking that we're
gonna run out of gas and we already
ordered food and verzi's sitting there
going not dude we're gonna make it we're
gonna make it
and we pulled in we made it we got the
food everything was great and i came out
to start up the [ __ ] suv little
poor excuse for an suv and it did the
start that's how low on gas i was it was
on fumes
unfortunately i read up a little bit on
uh cars
and i was thinking what if i pump it a
little bit and maybe i can get a few
drops out of the fuel line and get
across the street and it happened
started to [ __ ] her up you know
because my dumb ass that's how little i
knew about cars i wouldn't i wouldn't
have stepped on the gas more i would
have thought
that i just would assume there was
nothing left um
and then we ate it and then the next day
my stomach was ten times [ __ ] bigger
but you know what i stand by it i had a
great time listen to paul versus uh
podcast i guarantee you
the versi effect he brings it up this
week um
all right let's get back to the uh let's
do a little advertising here a little
frick little frack here
uh stamps.com everybody i've already
told you how not to have to ever go
and have to buy uh what do you call
blades for your razor
anymore so already right there that's
one less trip you have to make out of
the house
where's his one last trip number two
so that would be two less trips unless
you decided to go run errands
and do them both at the same time i
don't know how you live your life
all right stamps.com everybody with the
summer in full swing
there are a lot of places we want to go
but the post office isn't one of them
driving there parking waiting for a
clerk what a hassle man
why don't you just use stamps.com
instead stamps.com
anything else uh anything you would do
with the post office you can do right
from your desk
buy and print official u.s postage for
any envelope
any package any class of mail just use
what you already have your own computer
and printer
stance.com will make it easy and
convenient
it's like having a postal expert
available 24 7 whenever you need it
you'll never have to go to the post
office again i'm going to say that again
people
you'll never have to go to the post
office again
unless you're some weirdo that collects
stamps
i use stamps on stamps.com to send out
all my dvds i've never had a problem and
i'm a [ __ ]
right now use uh my last name bur burr
for this special offer no risk trial
plus 110 bonus offer offer includes a
digital scale
and up to 55 dollars free posts postage
it's always the last third don't wait go
to stamps.com before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the page
uh and type in bur that's stamp stop
calm and enter bur
all right legalzoom most most americans
don't have a will
but why well i guess a lot of us don't
own enough stuff
you know what a depressing way to start
it
let's start this one over everybody
legal zoom
most americans don't have a will but why
you don't want government rules
dictating what happens to your property
in minor children do you so why
procrastinate
most people say it's too expensive too
time-consuming too much of a pain in the
age
my answer to all your problems is
legalzoom.com
too expensive you're going to love legal
zooms reasonable prices
uh too time-consuming most people finish
the online process in just 20 minutes
20 minutes to protect your assets and
your family after you're gone
uh and we're not talking some fill in
the blank form you
your will is a state specific and
personalized
it's personalized based on your
information best of all
legalzoom has 12 years of experience
helping people with important legal
matters
it's national make a will month everyone
so don't wait any longer
from the people who want to make money
off making wills everybody it's
national make a will month go to
legalzoom.com today and get 15
off your last will but this offer ends
soon or a living trust and you'll
receive
a poor overwill absolutely free um
that's it people you should do it you
know what i should do it i haven't even
done it yet
mia's been on me you know what i'm gonna
go to legal zoom just like you let's
have a race
who can get their will done first uh to
get your special discount be sure to
enter burr in the referral box at
checkout for wills powers of attorneys
trusts and more
go to legalzoom.com legalzoom can
provide self-help services at your
specific direction or connect with an
attorney
but they are not a law firm all right
there you are there you are let's go
back to the podcast everybody you know
what
i've been running my yep talking about
myself long enough
i have an idea i have an idea as they
say why don't we read a couple of
letters
bulgaria bulgaria everybody that's in
eastern europe just south of the ukraine
capital is uh don't tell me
ah [ __ ] i had this one
is that sophia was that belarus look at
that i didn't polish up on him for one
[ __ ] week
no it's sophia
right then what the hell is belarus
ah christ i can't even [ __ ] remember
anymore
what an [ __ ] yeah it is sophia but
what's belarus now i'm looking it up
[Music]
oh i can't sing that song or else the
ghost of uh
big-headed moe there he gets the money
not pat sajak what the [ __ ] his name
yeah gives a [ __ ] all right bulgaria i
heard you mentioned bulgaria in the last
podcast
the hairs around my [ __ ] rose up in
excitement that you would visit
i checked your schedule and there are
only two euro cities listed
go [ __ ] yourself you [ __ ] um
despite your tone despite how insulting
you just were
i feel as though that um
you really don't feel on that i just
feel you're disappointed
all right so i'm going to plow through
all your anger that you just sent me and
i have to ask you this
bulgaria is one of those those countries
i don't know anything about
and as an american if you don't know
anything about the country you have to
assume
that it's a dangerous place for
americans to go part of that is
ignorance the other part is our foreign
policy
we've pissed off a lot of people so i
have to ask you this
you seem to have command albeit in an
angry way of the english language could
i actually go to bulgaria and if i do
what is what is there to do there is it
war-torn
have you made a comeback let me let me
hear about bulgaria
and in general let me hear about eastern
europe what's going what's going on over
there at bosnia and herzegovina
slovenia slovakia house and fairfield
corporate
we're gonna do it just a couple of
eastern europe [ __ ]
making beer and [ __ ] milwaukee we're
gonna shave our mustaches for you
potato dilemma hey billy redface i find
myself at
a big career decision point in my life
and i'm not completely sure what to do
i'm a 22 year old guy and i study
languages at a university here in
finland
oh home of nokia um on many summers
i've worked for a potato packaging
company that is owned by my father's
side of the family
that's [ __ ] awesome see that right
there you know why that that guy
and his family are secure is that is
about as tangible as it gets
potatoes you can hold them in your hands
you stick them in a package
right just like the old days
recently my cousin who works there um
regularly at works there regularly asked
me whether i'd be interested in joining
him and taking over the company
as the old owners my uncles and my dad
are retiring soon
i never had much of a relationship with
my dad but he'd still
likely be happy to have one of his
children take over
now i don't really know if i should
accept the offer i would likely secure
it would likely secure me a pretty good
living in my adult life but the thought
of being able to see my future laid down
before me
like that is a bit scary so far i've
never really planned ahead and honestly
i end up in the university studying
english just because i didn't know what
else to do
well you know as far as i know about uh
finland over there don't you guys pay
like 90
tax but everything's taken care of you
know
health insurance college uh tuition is
is all paid hence don't you guys have a
problem
over there with people like you young
people who don't know what they want to
do
everything's taken care of why go out in
the real world and have ninety percent
of your check go out the window
for [ __ ] that you're not going to be
using unless you get a [ __ ]
hemorrhoid
right they kind of created the terminal
college student
um i'm just asking anyways this has led
to some lack of motivations in my
studies
as i don't really know where i'm going
going with it at all
um i just haven't had a plan by the way
how great is this guy's english
he's better than me i just haven't had a
plan and i've always felt like a bit of
an underachiever in my family he knows
the word underachiever
i know some french words i don't know
what underachiever is
achiever it's a five-syllable [ __ ]
word i barely use that in my own
language
i applaud you sir um with all my older
siblings
having gone to successful careers in
education and medicine
from their university studies where i've
just been drifting along with no
destination so far
as a regular employee the work in the
potato company has never been terribly
exciting but as the owner i'd obviously
have more control on what kinds of
things i could do
there's also the possibility that i
could refocus my studies into something
more business oriented
uh maybe taking over the marketing side
of things in the future should i accept
this offer or should i wait until i
found a career path i feel more certain
about
i just don't know if i'm ever going to
find it obviously i'm lucky
to even be in this situation uh but it's
just a bit overwhelming to have such a
big decision
uh to make at this age which i haven't
really thought about seriously before
thanks have a good day and go [ __ ]
yourself
um dude this this decision's all gonna
be in your gut
you're gonna have to go with your gut
dude i can't i can't make the decision
what you should do with your life
um i do feel that you should have a
passion
if you wanna have fun at work uh for
what you do
and um you know but if you're just kind
of floating around aimlessly you know
huffing out of a bong
maybe this could could be a good thing
for you i'm just playing devil's
advocate i don't know what you're doing
all right and i also imagined that you
know if you take this
and you don't like it you could always
sell your stake in it
to uh the other person your cousin or
whatever that you're going to go into
business with so it does give you
an asset which is something that a lot
of young people don't have
um gives you a little bit of footing i
don't think it's the worst thing
i mean i don't think potatoes are going
out of style are they people always
going to need potatoes
um i don't know but at the end of the
day dude you're gonna have to make
you're not gonna have to make that
decision um
personally i would not want to be in the
potato business but i would love to grow
some in my own yard
by the way everybody i told you about
how we planted some cucumbers
and uh tomatoes and peppers
i can't recommend it enough when they
finally
are ripe and you bring them in it's it's
like [ __ ]
magic and i live in a climate out here
where i can grow them all year round i
haven't had the tomatoes yet
but nia picked one and sent me a video
she bit into
it like an apple and um i don't know if
you guys know a lot of you know with the
tomatoes
a lot of just vegetables in general they
pick them before they're ripe
and they let them ripen on the truck but
basically the second you pull it off the
vine
you know it's not getting any more
nutrients and that's why a lot of like
especially tomatoes
just suck at least in this country
which is why when you order a caprici
salad you know
they have to put that balsamic
vinaigrette on it to give it a little
bit of a [ __ ] uh
the balsamic whatever the [ __ ] they put
on it to give it a little zip to make up
for the sugar
that's not in in the tomatoes that sweet
taste that's not there the same thing
when you make your pizza sauces you got
to throw some sugar in there
because the tomatoes over here suck but
if you grow your own
um you don't have to worry about that
the only thing you have to worry about
is knowing when to [ __ ] take them off
which
i [ __ ] up with the cucumbers i took
them off too soon
um but it's the greatest thing ever so
getting back to the
uh what you're doing here sir and by the
way i'm gonna have a whole [ __ ]
garden
you know and then i figure what i'm
gonna use for protein is
uh the rabbits that i kill that try and
steal my vegetables
i'm gonna be eating a lot of varmints a
lot of [ __ ] uh
some rabbit stew some possum soup you
know
a [ __ ] raccoon burger you know
cider rabies um yeah dude i would you're
22 years old i mean i
i don't at 22 i really don't think you
should know what the [ __ ] you want to do
with your life um buying in on a
business is some [ __ ] old man [ __ ]
you should at least own one pair of
suspenders before you make a decision
like that i would think
um but i get what you're saying like
this this
this window of opportunity might not be
open when you're 23
and then what if you [ __ ] don't find
something else
um you know something dude by the time i
was 22
i knew i wanted to be a comedian so at
22 if you don't they feel you want to be
a potato farmer
then that's probably a pretty good
indication
you know although you also have to take
into effect that
i i've taken too i don't know how the
expression goes you gotta factor in the
fact that
i'm superimposing when i figured out
what the [ __ ] i wanted to do
onto your life okay some people don't
figure out until they're 40.
so i would go with my gut all right and
have faith in yourself
as a human being that yet you know your
life is your life and you're on your
journey
okay and when you meet the person you're
supposed to be with or you you me
you find the career you're supposed to
be
uh the job you're supposed to be doing
in life you're going to feel it
i'm telling you when you find that in
life that you you never question it
you know and there's this feeling of
relief and excitement
you know so unless you look at a field
of potatoes growing
and it gives you a lump in your throat
because it's so goddamn beautiful to you
i don't think you want to do it that's
what my gut says all right but like i
said that's a huge decision
decision you got to make it for yourself
okay i hope that helped
and uh go [ __ ] yourself right back at
you and i'll be over there in december
you know what the london dates selling
really well
i know i don't have them all up there
but i don't post dates until there's
ticket links because then i got to deal
with people going like well
when the [ __ ] ticks go on sale i
don't know
all right all right moving on weight
loss everyone
hey uh hey bill just wanted to say i'm
representing you here in maine on the
last couple of
episodes you've brought exercising and
fatty
oh you i guess brought up exercising and
fatties you forgot the up
and wanted to let you know that you've
given me an extra motivation to keep off
the weight
i've i've lost in nine months i've lost
a hundred pounds on the mark hang on a
second
good for you sir good for you that's 500
miles of capillaries your heart doesn't
have to pump through
every [ __ ] beat anymore i can't even
remember that's even right every
pound of fat is five miles of
capillaries
huh you [ __ ] kidding me that's why
even an extra 10 pounds
extra 10 pounds you're slowly killing
yourself 100 pounds dude
congratulations he goes at 22
and at 225 pounds i've never looked or
felt any better
the question i wanted to ask you is what
is your take on diets
i just control my portion sizes and lay
off junk food
also i try to drink at least 1.5 gallons
of water a day
ah dude you got to be careful with that
you can actually die from drinking too
much water
1.5 gallon you're a big guy though if
you're [ __ ] 225 pounds
you're still in shape um i would look
into that man
are you sure that's how much you're
drinking anybody listening to this
please do not go out and drink 1.5
gallons of water
in a day you're not you're supposed to
drink like eight glasses
and even you got to watch out there's
something where you can actually
literally
drown yourself with you the cell walls
like i can't remember they did this
radio contest whoever could drink the
most [ __ ] water
won an xbox and some mother went in
there to do it for a kid and she ended
up dying it's [ __ ]
horrific but anyways let's let's just go
back to this he goes is that
is that too much um i would i would go
to a doctor on this one buddy
um he says thanks for putting out the
podcast definitely keeps me focused on
my cardio days
thanks um do i believe in diets no i
don't i think they just make you
miserable i think it is portion control
and you cut out bad foods
you just have to get through those first
three four days to seven days
where you're you're not craving you're
not on that salt
sugar salt sugar you know back and forth
junkie most people even if they are in
shape like are still fighting that
battle
like uh i'm not in the best of shape but
i'm not in in bad shape either
but i fight that all the [ __ ] time
and i actually you know i got that ice
cream with versi
and the next day i was driving by it
again and i had the urge
to go back and get some more [ __ ] ice
cream
you know justifying it like well i'm not
gonna be here
i don't know how many more months if i
lived here i'd go here all the time but
i said [ __ ] that and uh i'm not gonna
lie to you i'm out here wishing i did
get it the second time
and um but i'm glad i didn't
so um the [ __ ] am i talking about yeah i
believe in
portion control dude if you just have
like you do the [ __ ] they say have a
protein the size of the palm of your
hand
and you just have vegetables with no
statues or cabs
you do that like before seven o'clock at
night
just drink water the rest of the night
no more just and then you go
just go for a walk around the block
before you go to bed
and then don't eat again for like 12
hours until you wake up at seven again
it just sucks the first
couple of nights then your body gets
used to it so you won't be uh feeling
those hunger pangs
and uh and then
you know you just keep doing that you
wake up you have [ __ ] oatmeal there's
nowhere
for the fat to go it has to leave it's
getting kicked out by good food
that's what i would do and you know what
i would do that i never really did i
would read up on nutrition
a great guy to actually follow on
facebook is eddie brill
from the dave letterman show stand-up
comedian um
like i learned so much [ __ ] just by
following him on facebook like he
he's he's broken it down all the way
down to the bottled water that he'd
rather drink out of the tap
from some of the [ __ ] that he's reading
about bottled water it's amazing but um
there's a bunch of stuff out there
there's other things you can do like eat
uh
eaten seasoned go
go to farmers markets and then actually
know what's in season like i'll tell you
right now peaches are in season
i've never been i never had peaches in
my diet i just
started eating [ __ ] that was in season
peaches and seasons are [ __ ]
unbelievable like if you get a peach
right now
you got to eat it over the sink it's the
smoke the most insane thing ever and one
of the greatest things you could ever
eat after uh
after cardio you know
i don't know so wait what am i [ __ ]
who's that guy with the candy stripe
shorts
you know with the tank tops and the
[ __ ] balding afro what the hell is
his name richard simmons
oh bill simmons here oh bill simmons
i'm supposed to be doing this podcast
we're [ __ ] trying to work out a date
uh where i can come in and do his
podcast all right a fat person saying
thank you look at me i'm i'm inspiring
the fatties
um dear bill bear billy aaron burr
i've been fat or obese most of my life
and i want to thank you for
shaming me into losing weight and
getting into shape
you see that shame works
most people might get offended when you
talk about fatties and gluttonous people
but i took your criticism and jokes to
heart and went from 430 to 220. wait a
minute
look at this he did it a little under 18
months and he goes i'm not done yet
i'm almost 40 years old and my goal now
is to get to 180 pounds
which i haven't been since i was in the
seventh grade
but i will settle for a little less than
200 pounds dude do you understand that
you basically just saved your [ __ ]
life if you're 40 years old and you're
430 pounds
you're not long for this earth okay and
the
greatest example when was the last time
you saw a 430 pound
70 year old how about a 60 year old
how about a 50 year old have you seen if
even like a 50 year old
you know you just you can't you can't do
it
you just can't [ __ ] do it so good for
you man um and you know anybody else
who's fat when i do these fat jokes i'm
i'm rooting for you man
i'm i try to make everything fun i make
fun of myself for going bald being a
redheaded [ __ ]
all right don't take it i want you to
lose all right
good for you dude that's insane that's
what 210 pounds
he lost a cornerback that's unbelievable
uh i am almost 40 years old now and my
goal all right
i read that part he goes i feel like a
new man but what i'm most i'm most happy
about
is how much my dick is growing
wow all right this just took a [ __ ]
left turn
he goes because of all of the blubber i
had i had
because of all the blubber i had no idea
but it looks like i had
i have at least an eight inch [ __ ]
and that makes me a lot more confident
about myself well dude how long have you
been fat you must have been fat
before puberty because you said you were
you you were 180 pounds in seventh grade
ah dude you were that kid right
they're playing shirts and skins and
you're sitting there praying praying to
god they don't
get you for skins ah man that's [ __ ]
brutal good for you
look at him after all these years he
found his dick
that's tremendous um he goes i know it's
going to be hard
but uh i work out at least two hours
each day
and five days each week thanks for being
a jerk off
some people need tough love i owe it all
to you ah i don't know man though i
i got you going but you [ __ ] did it
you work out
five two hours each day five days a week
look at this
comes full circle now you're uh you're
inspiring me
i was gonna take today off because i
flew on a plane be a big [ __ ] oh i flew
across the country
i can't go walk around the block um
good for you man that's [ __ ] awesome
all right now
now that you're actually going to live
past 50 do me a favor
speaking of 50 don't drive 50 in the
[ __ ] left lane
all right if you're making a left and
the light turns green get out into the
intersection so not only the guy behind
you but the guy behind him we can all
[ __ ] make it
all right other than that go back to
eating sundays because we can't use you
i'm kidding don't do it all right hulu
plus everybody
you've tried streaming hit shows on your
pc on hulu.com now it's time to try
to start your free trial of exclusive
content in your living room
and on your mobile devices on hulu plus
that's right they've taken hulu.com
and they've taken it to another level
with hulu plus you get total control to
watch thousands of shows wherever you
want whenever you want
use hulu plus on connected tvs games
game consoles game souls
see you notice my brain i get too far
ahead game consoles
blu-ray players roku apple tv
pc or watch from anywhere on your
smartphone
or tablet on demand at all times and
with hulu plus you can binge
on full seasons watch your favorite
current shows
and even watch a full series run of
classic tv shows it's endless
they've got community modern family
south park snl jimmy kimmel
family guy and much much more hulu plus
is only 7.99 per month everybody
all right less than a pack of cigarettes
but right now
they are offering an extended free trial
of hulu plus
that is only available to podcast
listeners take control of your tv
watching experience
go to the podcast page at billboard.com
and click on the hulu plus banner
for your extra extended free trial or go
to huluplus.com
bill again that's hulu plus banner on
the podcast page at billboard.com
or go to hulu plus dot com slash
bill all right and believe it or not
that i
believe that's all the uh advertising
right is that why i did i read them all
let's scroll through here yes i did all
righty
nothing but uh nothing but the jokes for
the rest of the way
all right let's read another letter
um where are we
all right hypocrisy of the female gender
oh geez come on guys
come on ladies you know what women
trash the guys let's have this [ __ ]
be balanced here fair and balanced
all right what do we got here
hypocrisy of the female gender my
[ __ ]
my batteries are gonna run out here i
gotta get through this one quickly hey
bill aka
aka bill jazette shot
during the summer that really has
nothing to do with my name
that's just sort of my first name and
then a [ __ ] shot
but you know you tried he goes i'm in a
bit of a pickle
ladies he's got jills he's got a phallic
vegeta is that a vegetable
it's a pickle a vegetable or a fruit
well let's see bill you're planting
cucumbers
it's not on a tree it's in the ground
it's a [ __ ] vegetable
look at me mr [ __ ] green jeans here
anyways could be serious could be just
something that'll blow over but i'd like
your opinion anyway
um here we go a few days ago
while i was getting a coffee i saw my
girlf
girlfriend's best friend kissing a dude
that doesn't
look like her boyfriend but like the
rational human being that i am
i thought i asked my girl before i
jumped to any conclusion
so i asked her if her boyfriend's still
her boyfriend she said yes and asked why
so i told her
what i saw and her reaction is something
i didn't expect
she went silent so i asked her if she
already knew
and said and she said yes and begged me
not to tell the guy
so i said that i'd like to hear your
hear this
wait so i said that i'd like to hear the
story first
oh my story first
i don't know i'm just going to read the
way i wrote it so i said that
i said that i'd like to hear the story
first so i can assess
how i want to go about the situation i'm
sorry and she refused
so i said i guess it would be the same
way if you were cheating on me huh
you would act the same way and you two
would conspire over it
and she denied that started crying and
said she would never cheat on me
i told her it was [ __ ] [ __ ] that
she's implying that this
[ __ ] of a best friend has even the
slightest legit reason to be a piece of
[ __ ]
and i eventually left to go get some air
though it was difficult since she caused
a scene and started screaming down the
hall for me
i love when they do that right because
me the second a woman starts screaming
in public the guy's like at the very
least
a borderline rapist um
all right well so far
okay um you know i'm going to just read
the rest because at that point she was
breaking down crying and asked me to
come back but i was [ __ ] done
the funny thing is about this the funny
thing about this is
i barely even know the guy i met him
like twice he seems like a cool down to
earth guy and all
but i don't really owe him anything yet
what's happening just triggers something
in my mind and i feel like i should tell
him
multiple people know his girlfriend is
cheating on him and he has no [ __ ]
clue
i really lost a lot of respect for my
girlfriend but she's always talks about
loyalty and how important it is to her
and how she hates cheaters because she
knows how it feels to be on the other
end
what a [ __ ] hypocrite when confronted
with the situation head on
she just excuses it and mitigates it
with secret
what she mitigates it with secret court
nsa legal reasoning
so i have to believe i don't know did it
cut out
is it cutting out hello hello hello
something sounds weird i think it's
still taping right
oh jesus all right trying to read even
faster here
um the [ __ ] is going on with the sound
now
hang on hang on hang on there we go i'm
back
and i'm back um this is the worst read
ever i'm sorry because this is very
interesting
uh i can't even look her look at her or
talk to her right now just thinking
about the way she reacted
to to all of this still pisses me off so
what should i do here do i tell him
i don't know maybe i should just say
[ __ ] him he can't save the world right
and what about my girlfriend she's quick
to say cheating's wrong until her and
her group
are on are the ones doing the cheating
am i just slowly riding along this [ __ ]
to eventually
to eventual heartbreak help me out bill
you sexy beast you
um all right well there's a lot of
variables here uh
it it's really the cheating girlfriend
has put your girlfriend in a position
um where she's
dragged her into her [ __ ] you know
where now she has to choose between her
friendship to her
and her feelings about cheating and
um i imagine it's her friend she loves
her and she doesn't want to
blow up her life um
i don't know i think i think what really
needs to happen here
is you don't need to get involved
i think your girlfriend
needs to go to her girlfriend
and tell her the situation that her
cheating has put herself in
and that she needs to [ __ ] end it
with this other guy and grow up and
start acting like a [ __ ] adult
because her piece of [ __ ] behavior is
affecting
your girlfriend's relationship and
where you never had trust issues you now
do you know
i'm not saying that your your your
thoughts that your current girlfriend
will now cheat on you
are unfounded but there's two sides to
loyalty too where you know you can you'd
help your friend move a body
you know there's people like that like
you know
this cheater might be stringing your
girlfriend along going i know i'm just
confused right now
i'm sorry i just need i feel like i need
something different but i still love
mike and i'm trying to i'm just doing a
little
dick shopping i'm sorry i had to see it
it's like the [ __ ] farmer's market
whatever the [ __ ] she's saying
right um
[ __ ] her friend i feel bad for the other
dude what are you gonna do i would just
sit down with your
your girlfriend and just be like look
this is what hap this is what has to go
down
all right you know what whatever the
[ __ ] i just said
you need to go talk to your girlfriend
and tell her that she needs to [ __ ]
clear up her situation
uh because it's affecting my
relationship okay grow up break up with
this other [ __ ] guy
you know and uh get on with your life
that that's what i would suggest
and um and but i don't think you're
wrong to now be looking at your
girlfriend like what the [ __ ]
and uh i never believe when a woman
cries when you call him out on [ __ ]
i never do because i don't believe that
i don't believe the crying
as a rule because they can cry on cue
like meryl streep you know
um they just they just have access to
that emotion
and uh it automatically makes them the
victim it makes you feel like you're a
bully
i think you're 100 right to feel the way
you did uh you might have gone at her a
little too strong uh i've given you an
option uh i hope it works out for you
um in the meantime do you think you're
gonna marry this girl
because if you don't you're just wasting
time and this is a great [ __ ] uh
jump off point to get the [ __ ] out of it
you know
nfl football starts next month that
money you're spending on her going to
the movies would look
very nice with the nfl package you got a
lot of options here sir
um good luck to you all right that's the
podcast for this week
thank you for everybody who came out to
my shows i really appreciate it
and thank you to everybody in the red
state tour um
for being patient i'm definitely getting
out there i'm still bringing the
t-shirts i'm still doing the shows i'm
just not doing them all
at once like i wanted to i don't get to
drive across the great state of montana
but i get to see some of it
i drive from boise over um
and i still get to go to deadwood i just
have to figure out when i'm going to do
it
but i'm definitely coming and i
apologize for the reschedule just
something beyond my control
so i couldn't say no i had to do it i
mean i mean who the [ __ ] am i
right i get eight lines in a movie i if
i get a bigger part i gotta take it
all right so this is not the last time
this will happen but i will promise you
guys
if i ever move a date i will always make
it up i don't say hey [ __ ] that city
because i know how this business works
you can get all the way up to winning an
oscar
and three years later you're in a movie
about talking babies
right i don't want to do that [ __ ] and
if i
[ __ ] over kansas city then they're not
going to come out to my show so i don't
take you guys for granted
and that is it everybody that's the
podcast for this week
god bless you go [ __ ] yourselves and
i'll talk to you next week